okay guys today i decided i was sick of
being unemployed i'm going to find rich
neighborhood houses because i figure
they know people that hire brought a
resume and i'm going to see if they know
anyone that's hired my brother brian
is so nice he is the one that is going
to be driving me around and
watching me get rejected i'm pumped or
maybe not who knows maybe i'll be
employed by the end of the day
so far i've been to a couple houses but
i've only gotten people home at
two and they both one was answered by a
kid and he didn't
really seem to know what was what i was
doing the first one
um they just said they didn't know
anyone that was higher up yeah so
i'll i'll keep you guys updated hi
how are you how are you good i wanted to
see if you happen to know anyone that's
hiring
uh media and content creation
[Music]
people in these kind of um so yeah um
i do media and i've worked in sales
before but i quit that
media so you know anyone that is hiring
my number's on there
yeah of course okay thank you have a
good one
[Music]
hi hi i wanted to see if you happen to
know anyone that's hiring
oh for media and content creation
oh no would it be okay if i locked your
resume
just in case you ever think of someone
oh sure yeah
what do you do
oh okay yeah all right sure
yeah okay
house looks like no one's been there
since this shot oh
oh my god no way
bye i wanted to see if you happen to
know anyone that's hiring
and if i could maybe like drop off a
resume if you know someone
anna just went into this house
like that
how are you um so my name is pearl
and i had this idea where like i would
go to a nice neighborhood like
barrington and see if anyone here knew
anyone hiring
um so i wanted to see if i could leave a
resume and if you know anyone hiring
um so i do media and content creation
house is like
eerie but like i don't know inside it
hopefully she's okay
hopefully it's not jeffrey epstein
[Music]
a data entry operator scanner
okay yeah um could i leave a resume and
then if you happen to know someone later
what do you do what do you do
oh yeah so i did
need they did need data entry but i feel
like she was offended when i didn't know
what kind of job like that wasn't the
job i'm looking
today i probably talked to 10 people
which was harder than you think because
a lot of people weren't home but out of
the 10 i was offered one job
unfortunately it was as a data analyst
which i have no interest in
i quit my job to do something i'm
interested in comment what you think i
should do next time